casaya copine de la la young I Peppa is
a treaty named Duke we are angry son
will be so now is an upcoming husa
author many of his stories give voice to
young people who are discovering their
identity touching among other issues the
sensitive topic of homosexuality sonra
be so grew up in merciful melanie cape
town he's proud of his cultural heritage
but promotes respect tolerance and
acceptance between all people not
everybody agrees with him you're being
disrespectful to our house it doesn't
happen in the casa card so that two men
can be together or two females can be
together and you know my response has
always been that his character something
that we that has always been there is
cut a natural can you say it's natural
or is it something like that's created
by people over time for his latest
project sawa be so collected the life
stories of born frees young people born
after south africa's democratic
transition for 21 at 21 he interviewed
21 year olds who's honest voices give
critical insight on modern-day South
Africa so there was a change in 1994 and
we wanted to see in order to hear how
does it feel like to believe in a
democratic country you know now that
there's a change that everyone is equal
in in this country you know what are
your feelings about this country what
are your hopes and dreams for the future
what do you think about South Africa
right now one of his interviewees is
hip-hop artist janella tired yet come
sanwa bisa was impressed by her courage
to be openly lesbian janella lives in
the Cape Flats a neighborhood terrorized
by gangs and frequent violent attacks on
homosexuals nobody's going to stand up
for me and say leave the child alone
because society says yeah it's cool kill
them beat them up because they're the
devil's children you know her own sister
was brutally raped and murdered because
she liked your nella was openly gay so
on this is the house um 2010 20
that's where my sister's body was
discovered the idols in a dustbin behind
the house all I can say is that I'm cool
with it you know I've made peace with it
by writing about it we were told to born
free but they still struggle see walking
the summer day so his commitment does
not stop with the publication of your
Nellas story he regularly visits and
mentors his interviewees I look at
people like you're never and I know that
that the future is bright is right
because they are working working so so
hard but it doesn't have to be against
all these odds some of these things can
be can be minimized and reduced you if a
society could build bridges and in to
work together although ignorance and
violence are still prevalent after 21
years of democracy some will be so is
determined to continue his fight with
the power of words